troisième jour en corée du sud
[Musique]
- 0 je suis actuellement en restant
assis en tailleur alors bien stabilisé
poser aujourd'hui au programme nous
allons aller dans un stand de tir j'ai
jamais tiré de ma vie j'ai envie de voir
ce que ça fait parce que dans les jeux
vidéos on tire tout le temps passe des
milliers d'heures à tirer avec des armes
virtuelles j'aime pas spécialement les
armes à feu jusqu'aux décors et la
sensation de tirer voilà surtout je
détestais ça fait flipper je voudrais
tout d'abord le dirigeant j'en sais rien
j'espère que la presse vidéo vous a plu
elle m'a foutu mais 1 pouces blanches
dessus abonnés audi a tout à l'heure
dans un stand de tir comme cindy d'art
le père de la petite se dire merci mes
schémas guardiola bétique de stand de
tir et juste au dessus d'une banque la
banque et là je me braque une banque c
isin des amis on y est je dois choisir
avec quel pistolet tiré un choix entre
sitruk dont le glauque et le s p en tant
que joueur de counter strike j'avoue que
dans quel état mais j'ai dû passer sur
mon téléphone parce que j'ai pas le
droit d'amener ma caméra là dedans juste
la gestante de tir mais je crois que je
pouvoir glisser mon téléphone dans un
truc pour me filmer ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle ça fait des cours d'eau ou des
gros bruit gêne pas du tout
c'est impressionnant j'ai très peur
qu'elle s'arrête à mon tour
[Musique]
ok des amis je viens de sortir de cet
endroit
ok a dit qu'ils veulent apprendre des
trucs ça fait un bruit mal à écouter je
me suis fait chier dessus c'était
vraiment flippant en avant mais mal de
manière je supporte pas trop les gros
bruit est là quand tu tire une balle ça
fait un bruit mais de manière mental
donc ça me terrifie mais j'ai tiré des
balles j'ai fait un score de 91 points
donc en moyenne je tiens pas au milieu
je tiens dans le sac juste après voilà
j'ai le même stylo au tir comme
fléchettes à tout ce qui bloque je
connais bien on va traiter un [ __ ] de
recul quand tu tires est encore j'avais
locke donc c'est pas un recul de malades
par rapport est un col toute chair est
pourquoi je prends même type vague de
chaleur tranquillement sur le visage
c'est assez ouf je referais pas kaka
culotte ça par contre ça je referai
plein de fois ça un grand merci à un ado
you l'agent ce qui m'a permis de tirer
des balles aujourd'hui et qui est
responsable de mon traumatisme on va
rejoindre un ami qui s'appelle fabien
c'est le pote qui vit ici depuis des
années maintenant il va nous faire
visiter une université pour cheikh
m'bengue assure fabien ça à fabien et
enfin bien c'est l'un des rares hommes
qui étudie à l'adversité dans laquelle
on va se rendre aujourd'hui quoi vous
montrer parce que c'est l'université la
plus grande du monde sait ça
l'université de femmes là deux femmes
donc celle qu'on préfère finalement
l'absout dans une université de femmes
voilà est-ce que ça c'est un bon plan ou
pas
ça un plan plutôt pas mal mais 8 go
plutôt pressant et en fait c'est
totalement immense il a pu l'intégrer
parce que tu es un étranger mais pas de
nationalité coréenne c'est à dire que
les meufs quand elle voit un mec de
l'université c'est forcément à
l'étranger haoues forcément d'étrangers
soit c'est un corps et un pervers qui
est venu ici pour la relaxe de photos
arrivent assez régulièrement huawei à
temps et ses universités mais aussi un
centre commercial quoi elle avait
carrément une boulangerie
et puis tu attends c'est cette structure
a été fait pour que quand tu fais un
blog ça résonne un max et jean il te
regarde mal la cuisine coréenne de
famille honnie voilà c'était l'instant
trop beau merci à tous nous pénétrons
dans l'enceinte du bâtiment à des
restaurants tranquillement énormément
d'étudiants en ce moment puisque nous
sommes dans une période d'examen
natation anecdotes exceptionnel dans 3 2
1 tu gagne des points quand tu vas à
l'église si on fait ça en france sa part
en guerre civile il ya carrément une
salle de sport dont l'université tu t'es
mis bien fabien salles de sport j'étais
comme dans le clip de
colas mais attention extrait c'est
incroyable cette vidéo géniale
mais par contre ça t'a pas empêché
d'avoir un corps de lâches
c'est les vacances on est le 31 décembre
il ya des gens qui sont en train
d'étudier derrière moi [ __ ] l'espace
est immense quoi c'est complètement
après je n'ai pas très fort en maths
ouais c'était là une blague de niveau un
lieu aussi à une partie crèche ici
voilà ou alors ils sont très forts et
ils ont beaucoup à l avance je sais pas
ok c'est bien s'est réfugié dans un
bowling qui est en fait une boîte de
nuit
lucas dumont à toutes les pistes il nous
faut attendre dans une salle où tu peux
faire du ping pong à
[Applaudissements]
la technique du fils de [ __ ] que tu as
envie d'insulter
15e match de titans la piste de bowling
[Musique]
m
tout va se jouer à tout va se jouer avec
les lancers attention c'est terrible
[Musique]
com
e
après cette triste défaite fabien a
voulu me consoler en allant dans un café
pour chats poissons du monde de brutes
un manque d'amour et de paix et de fait
la ps move c'est que dans ce cas fallait
en fait les chats ils sont à l'adoption
c'est à dire que c'est un point qui
reprocha tu peux repartir avec l'adopter
vraiment lamentable non mais j'en ai
déjà deux à la maison sa voix à celle de
17 ans voire échappent à ce que le hajj
hamoud me manques tu as tes les blogs
finalement quand je suis pas chez moi
[Musique]
voyait rouge marche il mange et dans ce
cas fait là il ya même une sorte de
petite mezzanine pour aller dormir avec
des chats là ok même un mitage c'est
leur petit robert compartiment comme ça
pour se poser et le chat via nect a pris
bonne défaite au bowling rien ne pouvait
mieux me consoler et tranquille
attention qu il fait vraiment sa taille
que
j'aime ça j'aime trop les trucs abîmés
et il est fâché il aime pas du tout ce
que je fais on va le laisser en paix il
a dû perdre au bowling aussi plus de la
bouffe et le maïs est cachée monde
trouvait le chat dans cet espace je suis
caché je n'aime pas les gens
[Musique]
elle
je guéris
pauli les 6 milliards erreur divise
[Musique]
les amis les 6 heures du matin ici en
corée et je suis en mode igloo car il
fait très très très très très froid les
températures négatives et en fait c'est
la guerre aux taxis c'est à dire que il
ya un milliard de personnes qui
cherchent un taxi et y a que 20 taxi et
ça fait déjà une heure qu'on marche très
bien mais on a bien où ça c'est beau on
a craqué pour une petite serre arcade et
on s'est régalé au québec arrivé sur
suffisent actuellement en train de
décider il est huit heures du matin et
je dois dans deux ans on me lever pour
aller prendre le train direction pusan
c'est la deuxième plus grande ville de
corée c'était vraiment génial il ya la
mer là bas il ya un immense marché où
ils vendent un max de produits de la mer
le blème c'est que j'aime pas du tout
les produits de la mer mais c'est pas
grave j'aime le poisson aimez-vous les
fruits de mer où êtes vous plutôt viande
abonnez-vous pas là au revoir
aux la caméra
[Musique]